today one of the most important
buildings in the entire valley
is fulfilling a very important task but
the convention center isn't boosting
business it's vaccinating people
hector mejia live there right now with
details on this new second
dose facility hector good afternoon and
this is a push to administer
more second doses of the kovi19 vaccine
but you must be eligible
and have an appointment otherwise you
will be turned away
the convention here is only for those
who got the first dose through the
southern nevada health district or its
partners the convention center
so far fewer than one and a half percent
of all adults across nevada have been
fully vaccinated against covid19
the health district says nevada receives
about 30 thousand doses a week from the
federal government
up to twenty five thousand of that is
given to the health district but that's
not enough
to keep up with demand that's according
to officials at the health district
we've heard from people who say they
have not been able to make an
appointment
or that the next available date is past
the time they should be getting the
second dose
i asked the health district just how
widespread that problem is
and what they're doing to fix it
right now with limited supply of vaccine
it's very widespread
i mean really we can only set up
appointments and release enough
appointments for the amount of vaccine
that we have on hand
as you've seen across the country in
other states and jurisdictions where
they booked out
appointments for weeks and weeks and
weeks didn't have enough vaccine to
provide that
the health district adds appointments
are limited because they are allocated
based on shipments which could change
weekly so they recommend
for you to keep checking the website
repeatedly and we also learned
that fema is on hand but in a supporting
role
reporting from the las vegas convention
center hector mejia
8 news now